Okay, I'm going to throw some
terms at you, get ready.
You can describe a tree
in terms of levels, or
how many connections it takes
to reach the root plus one.
The root is level 1, and nodes directly
connected to it are on level 2.
Nodes in a tree are often described as
having a parent child relationship.
In this system,
a node at a lower level is a parent, and
the node connected to it at
a higher level is a child.
A node in the middle can
be both a parent and
a child,
it depends what it's being compared to.
Keep in mind though this isn't a real
family tree where children all have two
parents.
Here, children are only
allowed to have one parent.
If a parent has multiple children,
those children are considered
siblings of each other.
You can talk about
ancestry in a similar way.
A node at a lower level
can be called an ancestor
of a node at a higher level
which is the descendant.
The nodes at the end that don't have
any children are called leaves or
external nodes.
A parent node is called
an internal node.
You can call connections edges, and
a group of connections
taken together as a path.
The height of a node is the number
of edges between it and
the furthest leaf on the tree.
A leaf has a height of zero but the
parent of a leaf has a height of one.
The height of a tree overall is
just the height of the root node.
On the flip side, the depth of a node
is the number of edges to the root.
Height and depth should move inversely.
If a node is closer to a leaf
then it's further from the root.
[SOUND] Glad that's over with.
Time to learn some more about trees.